así es rodrigo ya en campaña electoral
se vio que estas consultas
interpartidistas ganaban en peso
mediático respecto a las elecciones
legislativas del senado y de la cámara
de representantes para destacar que se
han cumplido las expectativas previas de
campaña a los sondeos y por ejemplo el
pacto histórico donde aún continúan
celebrando han tenido el gran éxito con
gustavo petro teniendo más de 4 millones
y la segunda persona más votada de la
lista francia márquez ha obtenido más de
700.000 siendo la más la tercera más
votada sólo por detrás de federico
gutiérrez que es el que se ha llevado el
máximo de votos en el equipo por
colombia la coalición de derechas con
más de 2 millones de votos por encima de
otras fórmulas como david barguil del
partido conservador con un gran aparato
del partido detrás o alejandro char que
es uno de los políticos más famosos de
la costa atlántica por último también en
la coalición de la esperanza las peleas
que han habido en las últimas semanas
les ha passat factura y aunque ha ganado
el candidato previsto sergio fajardo sí
que han basado en cantidad de votos
louis como comentaba es el pacto
histórico y gustavo petro son los
grandes ganadores de la noche pero petro
ha apuntado en su discurso que lo que
pretende con el frente con el pacto
histórico es que sea un frente más
amplio y ha ofrecido algunas coaliciones
a otros partidos verdad
si sorprendentes palabras abriéndole las
puertas también a los conservadores y
otras fórmulas distintas a la izquierda
que él representa sólo aquellos que
estén en contra de la corrupción y
respeten la ética ajustado petro estaba
exultante sobre la tarima hablando de
una victoria inmensa en la que asegura
que han sacado más de seis millones de
votos llegando a tener más del 45 por
ciento y esto le ha hecho ser muy
optimista de cara a la próxima vuelta a
la próxima elección presidencial del 29
de mayo donde asegura que están a un
paso de ganar las presidenciales por
mayoría
como escuchamos los gritos de júbilo y
voy a aprovechar para hacer un cierre de
resumen diciendo que para mí está viendo
los resultados del pacto histórico
gustavo petro que es el gran ganador que
se ha enfrentado a una derecha fuerte y
unida iu donde vemos el centro y ha
pasado factura de las peleas internas y
se ha hundido
[Aplausos]